Before discussing the standards,
we need to differentiate
between a declarative versus
a procedural specification.
To do this, we'll use baking a cake.
Well, you know how to do that,
don't you?
The declarative statement
expresses the desired results, but
does not say how to achieve it.
The procedural statement provides
a recipe for achieving the goal.
Think back to the to the curly braces
problem with the Arden Syntax.
It's really the same thing.
Arden provides a declarative
standard but the procedure would be
different depending on the system
that is the source of the data.
The hQuery Gateway similarly receives
a standard query on one side,
but knows how to get
it done on the other.